vemos una revisada a todo lo que hemos
visto en los vídeos anteriores para
después tomar unos pasos a partir de ahí
digamos que tenemos una realidad que en
este momento que aunque no es la
verdadera tasa de intercambio actual voy
a usar estos números para facilitarme
los cálculos la tasa de intercambio
actual es de 10 yuanes por un dólar de
eeuu y ahora estamos en una realidad en
donde el gobierno chino y su banco
central quieren mantener esa tasa de
intercambio fija constante quieren
asegurar esta tasa de intercambio pero
la realidad es que se venden más cosas
de china hacia eeuu hay más exportación
de china a eeuu que al revés y esto nos
lleva a esta dinámica particular que
vimos en los vídeos anteriores aquí
tenemos a china
y aquí tenemos a eeuu de américa
y digamos que con esta tasa de
intercambio se tienen productos que
están siendo enviados desde chinas y
eeuu
aquí hay mercancía de china que está
siendo enviada hacia eeuu
y aquí se paga por esa mercadería china
en dólares y esos dólares se envían a
china imaginemos que en este periodo de
tiempo que es de un año se pagaron 100
dólares por toda esta mercancía china
son 100 dólares enviados a china por la
mercancía y todo esto es revisión de lo
que vimos en los vídeos anteriores por
otra parte tenemos algunos productos o
mercancía enviada de eeuu hacia china
son exportadas
se venden en china y de regreso se
obtienen yuanes y en la vida real pues
no tenemos el dinero dentro de un barco
que se ha enviado de china de eeuu todas
las transacciones se realizan mediante
cuentas bancarias y todas estas tasas de
intercambio se realizan básicamente en
internet pero esta es una buena manera
de visualizar esto así que se vende la
mercancía de eeuu en china y el
productor recibe yuanes y digamos que en
este ejemplo va a obtener 500 yuanes y
teniendo esta dinámica aunque finalmente
no sabríamos cuál sería el punto de
equilibrio ya que toda esta demanda y
oferta va cambiando con el tiempo si
quisiéramos convertir esos 100 dólares
que recibe el productor en china hacia
yuanes con esta tasa de intercambio 10 a
1 se necesitaría y vamos a suponer que
esto es lo que el gobierno chino quiere
así que esta persona necesitará vamos a
escribirlo acá
esta persona necesita mil yuanes
para poder convertir todos los 100
dólares en yuanes con esta tasa de 10
yuanes por dólar por otra parte el
fabricante en eeuu tiene 500 yuanes para
convertir en dólares y aquí debo de
poner necesita entre comillas sino aquí
hasta yuanes tiene 500 yuanes para
convertir en dólares
y esto ya lo hemos visto varias veces
pero de verdad quiero que quede esto muy
claro sobre cómo fluctuarían las monedas
la demanda de yuanes es mucho más alta
que la oferta que hay de estos y se
puede tener el mismo argumento para los
dólares la demanda de dólares es mucho
más pequeña que la oferta de dólares a
esta tasa de intercambio si suponemos
que está fija aquí sólo se tendrán 50
dólares que necesitan convertirse a
dólares cuando hay 100 dólares de oferta
en cambio aquí necesitan mil yuanes que
con esa tasa de intercambio sólo hay 500
yuanes como oferta para ser convertidos
a dólares en una tasa de intercambio o
flotante al aumentar la demanda de
yuanes este número va a bajar otra forma
de verlo es que este número baja o este
otro número aumenta se puede decir que
el yuan se vuelve más caro que podrían
ser 9 joanes por dólar 18 juanes por
dólar o lo podemos ver de la otra manera
que por 10 yuanes en lugar de tener un
dólar se puede recibir un dólar con 10
centavos o un 2
con 20 centavos de cualquier manera para
dejar esta tasa de intercambio fija
constante en el vídeo anterior vimos que
el gobierno chino en particular el banco
central chino tiene que intervenir
recordemos dónde está el excedente aquí
aquí tenemos 100 dólares que necesitan
convertirse ayudan es y de este otro
lado tenemos solamente 500 yuanes que
necesitan convertirse a dólares el
gobierno chino quiere que estos 100
dólares sean convertidos a millones así
que lo que ellos hacen es que ya hay 50
dólares que pueden convertirse a esos
500 yuanes de acá así que 50 dólares van
hacia el fabricante en eeuu
y esos 500 yuanes se mandan a china
obviamente esto no es coordinado no es
algo en el que se pongan de acuerdo pero
esencialmente sólo habrá 50 dólares que
podrán ser convertidos a joanes y los
otros 50 dólares que faltan para
completar los 100 que se necesitan irán
al banco central chino
aquí lo dibujamos banco central chino
y estos 50 dólares y dan aquí a este
banco de manera que van a imprimir 500
yuanes y los van a dar de vuelta y eso
es lo que vimos en el vídeo anterior
aunque lo dibuje un poquito diferente
pero aquí lo que les estoy mostrando es
que para compensar la falta de oferta de
yuanes cuando se necesitan 1.000 yuanes
y solo se pueden convertir 500 se
compensa cuando el banco central chino
imprime esos 500 yuanes que faltan y los
convierten a dólares básicamente es
absorber el excedente de dólares así que
de esta manera el dólar no se debilita
aquí se absorbe dólares extra de manera
que la oferta de dólares no sea
demasiada y este dólar no se debilite y
de esta manera los chinos pueden
mantener este desequilibrio en las
monedas y así podrán exportar más
productos de los que importan y cuál es
el efecto de esto ya habíamos visto que
para mantener esa tasa de intercambio
fija el banco central chino tiene que
seguir imprimiendo yuanes y
ir acumulando dólares así que aquí están
acumulando dólares
si alguna vez dejan de hacer esto dejan
de acumular dólares dejará de estar fija
la tasa de intercambio por lo que en
todo momento este banco central chino
tiene que mantenerse activo en el
comercio imprimiendo joanes y
convirtiéndolos a dólares quizás no día
con día pero siempre que noten que el
yuan está empezando a subir tienen que
hacer esto por lo que van a seguir
acumulando más y más dólares y aquí es
donde se pone interesante que va a ser
el banco central chino con todo este
efectivo que tienen dólares bueno como
en todos lados el efectivo es inútil
realmente solamente es papel y bueno si
nos permite comprar algunas cosas que
necesitamos para vivir o comprar cosas
que nos pueden dar algún valor pero el
banco central chino realmente no
conserva estos billetes de dólar lo que
trata de hacer es comprar o invertir en
los elementos más seguros de eeuu y aquí
otra cosa no se trata sólo de la
seguridad aquí
no solamente quiere ir por una
denominación dólar segura en bienes de
manera que se compra algo en dólares se
obtienen intereses en dólares así que la
denominación dólar segura de bienes se
va a realizar de una manera masiva de
cientos de miles de millones de dólares
incluso llega a los billones de dólares
así que no sólo pueden ir a comprar las
acciones de las compañías que no son tan
seguras sino que también van a conducir
el precio hacia el infinito si es que se
ocuparán toda esta cantidad de dólares
tiene que ser un bien líquido estos
bienes deben tener liquidez uno que
tenga un mercado bastante profundo las
personas que participan en este mercado
lo hacen con cientos de miles de
millones de dólares y sólo hay un bien
que cumple con estas características que
son los bonos del tesoro de eeuu
y bonos del tesoro de eeuu de américa
y esto no es todo lo que van a adquirir
pero la gran mayoría va a ser de esto
así que lo que hace el banco central
chino con este exceso de dólares es
comprar bonos del tesoro de los eeuu
enviar los dólares a las personas que
tienen los bonos del tesoro de los eeuu
y va a recibir estos bonos de vuelta así
que recibe esto de vuelta y ya habíamos
mencionado en otro vídeo de qué se
tratan los bonos del tesoro de eeuu
estos documentos básicamente son
préstamos al gobierno federal de eeuu es
la forma más sencilla de comprender que
son son préstamos al gobierno de eeuu
estos bonos del tesoro básicamente son
certificados de promesas de pago por
parte de los estados unidos por ese
préstamo y el gobierno de los eeuu
pagará intereses por este préstamo en
resumen el banco central chino imprime
dinero yuanes que convertirá a dólares
a dólares y usará esos dólares para ya
sea en el mercado abierto o directamente
del tesoro de los eeuu comprar estos
bonos que en resumen significa que ellos
están prestando este dinero al gobierno
de los estados unidos por lo que prestan
este dinero al gobierno de eeuu de
américa
vamos a dejarlo hasta este punto en este
vídeo y quiero que ustedes reflexionen
sobre esto ya que en el siguiente vídeo
veremos que ellos lo que significa esto
qué sucede si tenemos a esta entidad que
tiene muchísimos dólares y que los usa
para comprar bonos del tesoro que está
dispuesto a prestar este dinero al
gobierno de los eeuu en particular
quiero que piensen que es lo que va a
pasar con las tasas de interés y qué
impacto tendrán estos en el resto de la
economía de eeuu